hello and welcome back to this video
step by step Poland let's see i can get
live count the favorite line against his
opening in unfortunately didn't play
with them with the e3 and 92 i know i
know that it's not good but i'm kind of
sick with my play in recent game so i'm
going for something crazy em just go
forward direct attack and see if hear
how it offends against it so 3 2 g-3
probably coming so if i do this b5 as
probably on the cards let's see him how
do i get can I get some kind of a tech
going now chief for Queen g3 will
probably happen long Castle seagulls
beef is the thing and it's not good
I cannot castle long yet it's not good
there any other way of playing here if
four me Mia 2595 if i play Knight h5 I'm
threatening Bishop g4 a little bit
strange but cringe III is really quite
annoying so maybe just a dress that if
you place like h3 I go g5g form well
quite sure what one should play it's not
easy to play i mean what i did is
certainly not correct what r attend in
effect quite resigned oh my god yes
should i should try this kind of crap a
texan off and it seems to seems to
irritate quite a lot yeah i don't know
ok this is not objectively working in a
blitz game you can try many things but
you shouldn't here um no Liz to just
develop 97 or 96 I can also ask what the
engine think about it I like this
actually to have after a 3d for a
possible 95 well that said I was just
sick with a normal stuff just roll the
dice a little bit so let's see ya 95 is
what the engine wants to do but then it
gets kind of okay this is what I would
have played because the track you cannot
do this actually this looks like white
gets killed which is true it seems to be
true like this killed is a bit strong
for that evaluation but it's good for
black at least and this looks very
normal Queen f3 and i can take c4
actually which I didn't see I just
wanted to get pieces out so we should be
63 and tia which I castle long I was
concerned about this the engine not so
much thinks that this is okay I really
didn't want to put the night on the edge
of the board here you know that it's
absolutely it has an idea as i have just
painted but it does not relate to the
Kings side at all interestingly enough
the engine isn't even then skeptical
about my chances here just slightly
words it states yeah i played this
strange-looking move my idea was after
age three to play AG five
and then that it's also not so clear so
there is always some compensation with
those attacks probably not enough but
wow no it gets to zero remarkable I
really thought what I did was completely
like not working at all okay a queen ear
for is good I can yeah no good move I
mean why should be better somehow and
cannot believe it and took him it was
just a blackout by what ok guys thanks
for watching